yo what's the deal it's jason cash check
me out on the bullet calf show
bootleg cab show special guest
my guy just dropped his uh are we
calling this the album or we're calling
this a mixtape okay okay read the room
yes sir the new project finally out man
you were on the show i mean i don't know
a couple of times obviously uh
it's just good to see man you finally
got this body of work out cause i know
you're sitting on like a [ __ ] hundred
and fifty songs
[ __ ] that didn't even matter a lot of
stuff didn't make it um but yeah man
like uh how's it feel to finally get
this out
man
like amazing
it's a very good feeling it feel a
little weird though man like now that
people can hear the [ __ ]
that we was just hearing that i was
telling the homies hey don't let nobody
hear that you know guard that right now
everybody has access to it so it feel a
little weird you know but how difficult
was it because you do have so much music
you've been recording so much over the
last few years
how difficult was it to bring every like
cut cut everything down into one project
it was easy it was very easy because
most of the [ __ ] for read the room like
we caught a wave when we realized it was
read the room
so a lot of that music was made like in
a
i want to say like a two to three week
span if i'm not myself like over a case
of course in like a month
so
do you have your your stuff that you're
like yo this is for the quote-unquote
debut album yeah there's a song that i
wanted to put on read the room that um
jfk or the eastie boys he was like
he gave me like three calls like bro
take that off like you know like just
for the album it was more so like it
just didn't fit like
the energy of like towards the end of
this project the content-wise it was
perfect like it was something that i
really wanted
to say but he was like man if anybody's
gonna have like a uh i don't know moment
it's gonna be that song not because the
song isn't right but just for where we
placing it in terms of like in terms of
like if people were to press play on the
album from top to bottom that might be a
song that they'd be like that might
deter them from yeah just because it was
slower
and so we subbed that song out with
living proof the one with don kennedy
shout out to dom man
uh who shouted me out on here yes he did
i still am waiting for west side or
zelda to come out somewhere
i sent it to benny the butcher oh yeah i
mentioned it to uh i mentioned to benny
the butcher i seen him at um
he said he's gonna get you so he said
he's gonna get on it oh damn i didn't
know that i mentioned it i put him on
facetime with uh with simba and he's
like i got you send it over and we'll
see what happens i met him at like a
death row party snoop was having and i
like i told him like yo i got signed off
a song called west side risotto
so we we chopped it and it was just cool
but simba actually um
like last week he was like yo let's
shoot a video for that
so
i don't know man so that might be on
simba's album
i don't know
it might but yeah simba definitely just
asked me last week to shoot a video for
it hey man it's about time that song's
[ __ ] crazy
for you like uh
you know because i feel like there's
been a lot of anticipation for your
you've been on atlantic uh i feel like
for a while yeah like going on it'll be
two years in july in terms of just like
you played your music for a lot of
people right there's been a lot of like
damn jason's got some [ __ ] right right
whenever he you know whenever he gets
that button pressed
um
do you feel like any sort of relief in
terms of like finally just getting the
very first thing out in terms of like
since you because i feel like
sometimes you can overthink your first
project
um you know and i feel like it didn't
feel like that that was the case when
you listen to this album but do you feel
any like personal relief finally getting
it kind of off your chest
i felt it for a second and then it was
gone instantly
because it's like i'm in like a real
real like
awkward space in my career it's like i'm
not in the building
but i'm in the parking lot so it's like
some people like me but they don't love
me yet so it's like i could post
something on the gram today right and
he'd go crazy then i could post
something two days later and nobody taps
in because it's not really like the
popular cool thing to just be like oh we
[ __ ] with jason cash yet so i dropped
a project that i really feel is a great
body of work without like a large fan
base so
that relief that i felt of oh damn we
got it out
it
it immediately turned into pressure of
damn we got to get these people to hear
this [ __ ] yeah now that now that real
work starts not a real work start
because it's not like i had
a large ass fan base and then just
dropped a great body of work and
everybody's tapping in and now
everybody's sliding to it's like
i know once somebody press play on this
[ __ ] they're gonna [ __ ] with it but i
gotta get them to press play on this
[ __ ] what are those things that uh
because i feel like the one thing you
were doing early on that
was getting a lot of engagement was
doing your free styles in the car right
um freestyles on ig
um what are the things like now that you
feel like you need to do to try to
convert just hip-hop people into jason
cash fans
um for one like i'm not the most social
so like for one being outside letting
them
see me like you know
um and also just engaging my whole team
because it's not like
the whole jason cash thing is it's like
a package thing like the ec boys did the
whole project so it's like great great
name yeah eastie boys
they're from the east side yeah that's
amazing so empowering my team as well so
it's like it's it has to be kind of like
a force as opposed to just me because i
can't just get out in the car and just
rap every day like [ __ ] know i can rap
so after a while it's like oh damn you
can ride that's tight now if i go i can
go wrap something in the car right and
it'd be like it'll do what to do but if
i go wrap that same verse like sitting
down with somebody it'll do way more
than what it'll do coming out the car
now it's like we already know you can
rap it's sad but it's like you know this
music [ __ ] is smoking mirrors so they
want to see like the smoke on the mirror
like you know what i mean do you do like
because you know
just on some like real basic grass roots
level [ __ ]
i always tell like uh up-and-coming
artists to suit like engage with your
fans like do you like uh reply back on
comments do you yeah like it's i'm not
gonna lie like i used to respond to
every comment
but like it started [ __ ] with my
anxiety as more and more comments come
in like while you're taking a [ __ ]
bust open the phone see who's [ __ ]
with you be like you know like it you
know i feel like people really like
it's a small thing yeah but when you're
like starting out i feel like that [ __ ]
matters to people because they'll be
like oh [ __ ] nah yeah for sure sometimes
it's hard it got to a weird space of
like all right so i'll miss certain ones
and somebody a demon like damn you
responded to everybody ain't ignoring my
[ __ ] something's like well those people
are weirdos yeah so it'll be like all
right so let me just not say [ __ ] but i
go i go live a lot in the studio
and you know i play music or i just talk
to people
et cetera
[ __ ] like that you know what i mean and
a lot of times when somebody like repost
it you know i i'll respond when i see it
sometimes i just literally don't see it
why i might see it like way after the
fact and it's missing like what they
responded to but i try to respond and
engage as much as i can and when i'm
outside and i run into people i try to
be as cool as i can again like i'm not
man i'm human for one and i'm adjusting
to people like knowing me before i know
them and i also got shot so it's like
when somebody's just you got some
anxiety yeah like when somebody's just
random walking up on me sometimes it'd
be like you know in my mind i have to
remember like okay you're a rapper
especially because it's like i still
live my same life i'm still with the
same homies around the same way so it's
like
until i go certain places and somebody
asked me for a picture or somebody walk
up and tell me like yo i really [ __ ]
with you it don't be hitting me
sometimes that they're tapped into what
i'm doing you know what i'm saying
because i've been so used to just you
know
moving and maneuvering around the same
way yo what up man we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good folks at blue chew that's right
go to bluetooth.com fellas
you know sometimes
you go through some stress you go
through a little anxiety and your dick
is not
performing maybe how you'd like it's
called ed a lot of guys go through ed
you could just be old as [ __ ] if you're
watching this and your dick ain't
working like it did when you were like
20. you know what i mean well listen
buchu it is the wave uh how about this
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis getting delivered right to
your door in a chewable form in discreet
packaging and the best part about it is
it's all online
zero awkward visits to the doctor's
office zero you go online you sign up
with the promo code bootleg that's right
bootleg when you check out you will get
the first month for free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars on shipping and
you're gonna get one month's supply of
blue chew all right and you're gonna be
[ __ ] like you were [ __ ] never
[ __ ] before your dick's gonna i'm
gonna assume
you're adding at least a quarter of an
inch of erection that shit's gonna be
rocked up rocked up and socked up all
right boys so what you need to do one
more time go to bluetooth.com
and use that promo code bootleg and get
your first month for free
bootleg promo code bootleg on
bluechoo.com let's get back to the
interview
when someone gets shot i can only
imagine that you have to move around
with a certain level of ptsd or anxiety
yeah i mean
yeah fortunately like
i probably would be different if i got
shot in a situation that was intended
for me because i'll probably be scared
to go outside but then again the world
is so [ __ ] crazy that it's like so
your situation you got shot it was just
kind of wrong place a long time based on
the time like [ __ ] you know but that's
that's even crazy to talk about it like
that like it's just in l.a [ __ ] like
it's regular but right right right but
it's not like someone was seeking you
out to hurt you hell no um
yeah that's bad i mean that's definitely
better than like yeah so you you move
around it's a little easier to move
around knowing that like it wasn't
nobody that was like looking for jason
yeah but in the same breakfast like when
you're in crowds and you in places and
[ __ ] it's like you know this [ __ ] could
go up cause
bro just
you know i ain't even gonna do that
something happened recently hell yeah we
was
[ __ ] i'm gonna say i'm not gonna set
a place but me and the homies we went to
this day party right and we left this
day party and we went to this um this
bar and grill to watch the fight
god
so it's tight because i'm like okay this
the spot [ __ ] be at it's like
i'm outside it's like you know i'm
walking in you know homies like hey you
see them pointing at you yeah i'm
sitting there eating they play my son
they play uh top down and right after
top down they go into they play him so
i'm eating i'm dancing like oh this is a
vibe dog i go outside right i come
inside i'm like
i see my cousin i sent my um
i get i passed my cousin my drink i'm
like i'm gonna go to the bathroom
shots just ring out inside bro oh my
mama oh my god i'm hiding in the supply
closet oh hell no i've been in that
situation where
uh even recently i was in like uh
[ __ ] there's a shitty city outside of i
don't want to say shitty there's a city
outside of fresno that i dj'd in
i forget the name of the city but i'm i
i we ended up doing this bar
and
ten minutes left before the thing closes
[ __ ] just right out front just
gun shots right like a [ __ ] machine
gun right so like boy i was on the floor
bro i'm bro i've run to the supply [ __ ]
then i'm like [ __ ] i'm still hearing
scrambling and [ __ ] so now i'm hiding
behind the rack with the food on that
[ __ ] but
so apparent uh apparently they say that
it wasn't shooting inside the restaurant
was outside of it but it sounds close
enough
close as hell you know what i'm saying
and
bro so that happens right
the next day i had to host that
penthouse
and i went literally back outside the
next day and i'm like [ __ ] you know but
yeah you're like uh very much like uh
[ __ ] this happened yesterday now i gotta
go
like i'm like [ __ ] like yeah that shoes
that's crazy yeah that's that's
definitely uh i can't yeah i mean it's
kind of part of your job now right hell
yeah yeah that's why i'm like pull up
tap in that's part of the you know
that's part of this [ __ ] like so that's
why i don't really do too much like
clubbing or etc like just for fun or
just because because it's like i mean
i'm gonna be honest with you it was like
the kind of music you make like i'm not
sure like
i mean go go where you're paid to go
like obviously every once in a while
i'll pop out show your face but like i'm
not sure like you pulling up to
wherever the [ __ ]
is really gonna uh result in you getting
more fans or more streams see that
the thing is for me right
so fans and streams right that's
that's dope that's right but one thing
for me right now is like numbers versus
impact so it's like i know
my reach
like
my direct reach is what's around me like
i even this project read the room like i
want to super serve
los angeles the west coast like because
that's what i can reach out and touch
rather
somebody put a bunch of money up for
this that in the third like this is our
backyard this is where i can go pop up
at places like that where they know me
and they see me like oh i've been seeing
them on the gram that's him oh i [ __ ]
with him oh yeah i see him at this show
yeah i [ __ ] with him it's like so that's
the main thing it's not even so much
trying to convert it just to streams
it's really just impacting the city
because it's a lot of people
you can have a whole bunch of monthly
listeners and [ __ ] and nobody give a
[ __ ] about you whatever it happens a lot
no you definitely want to make sure the
city's behind you yeah so that was like
that was really my main thing
you know shout out to our guy a.d there
was a point in time where eddie was at
every [ __ ] nightclub
oh yeah i feel like he had i feel like
80 had stunt doubles in like 2017 and 18
because i'd be like
bro dawg i just seen yeah
what the [ __ ] and i feel like loki kind
of burned himself out a little because
he was doing all of the [ __ ] clubs
yeah but shout out to shout outs and it
wasn't as special when you would see a
dd yeah yeah shout out to shout out to
a.d that's my guy but my personality is
a lot different too yeah
oh man that guy's a maniac god bless him
and ot not for sure i've seen both of
them in the club like yeah that's not
really they weren't the pandemic wasn't
stopping
no they was going to scottsdale
but not yet that's not really my that's
not really my energy like you said
outside of like top down and [ __ ] like
that like my music that ain't really
like right right applies for it anyway
what is like in your opinion um in terms
of just like because i feel like um
you know la as a whole is
probably in its best uh
position it's been in since
i don't know the 90s depend who you ask
i mean look kendrick just dropped
the
we're talking about everybody from like
yourself to baby stone gorillas to i
mean we could go on and on and on right
um blasts i mean i just think uh
i also feel like there's a like a bit
more of
moving together as much as possible
obviously politics getting away a lot of
a lot of that but in terms of like some
of the younger cats like it feels like
they're somewhat a unified front even if
they're
you know not like super close it feels
like everyone's for the most part kind
of moving in the right direction how do
you feel i was explaining this to
somebody the other day it's like
what a lot of people don't know is a a
lot of us know each other
like already knew each other before [ __ ]
was cracking like i knew caitlin when
his name was young kay right i know
black you know blast way back when it
wasn't an x in this game you know what
i'm saying like
a lot of us know each other like that
i've been seeing each other move move
around so it's like
it's almost like once you get in the
club and you see somebody you know it's
like oh what's the deal bro let's let's
have a drink cause we all in the club
once you in the club then we can
function you know what i'm saying but
you still have to get
in the club so once you're in there you
can move you can move around that's why
in my opinion why why it seems like
there's that
that unity or camaraderie because again
like i said a lot of us
know each other like beno i don't go far
back with beno but
a couple years ago
blast was doing a show with beno and i
met beno like that so i met beno a
couple years before i had music out but
that's from he knew my boy so
even if we don't all know each other
like personally like that we know
somebody that know each other that any
kind of link that way so i feel like
that's probably why it seems that way
i saw you linked up with dre
of the doctor sort uh are you funny i
mean is there another drug
you know i worked with cool andre also
oh there's cool andre
andre 3000
have we checked all the dress off the
list no i've never met aj 3000. i've
seen him at complex kind but that's
about it me too and i [ __ ] he was in
the middle just painting some [ __ ] you
know what's crazy is i
that's the only time i was starstruck
and i didn't ask for a picture for real
because andre's like top five for me
yeah my wife was like just cook it i'm
like man he looks like he's just
enjoying the show yeah i don't want to
bother i don't want to be that guy yeah
i'm regret it though
but i'm i'm i'm to the point i i don't
even want to ask a picture if somebody
just take one it'd be like cool i think
the last person like i asked for a
picture was like
tom kennedy or something like that
i mean you get the dre picture for sure
yeah i took the dre picture but that was
like
two years ago i haven't um
i haven't seen him i saw you wearing a
snoop
yeah
so snoop damn do i ask for this new
picture no fuzzing noise be like yeah
let me get a picture y'all sorry i mean
yeah shout out to fuzzy because that's
what he should do
guys get a picture yeah yeah i won't be
having that because it's not as weird as
you saying yo what's up can we get a pic
yeah yeah your manager says hey guys
let's get a picture now yeah snoop man i
got a lot of love for snoop when i the
last time i seen snoop
um he don't even call me by my name and
then he was like what's up carson when i
sing
so
i got shout out to carson
uh
you have you seen uh
razz cast as a carson great i just ran
into razz cash damn what the [ __ ] are we
at when we sing
i'm talking to the east well have you
have you heard his son's [ __ ] coast
contra
oh i didn't know that was his son yeah
uh the two twins in the group are damn
they went viral with this [ __ ] so those
two twins the two of the four are uh the
twins are ras cass's sons oh that's dope
which is [ __ ] crazy damn i just where
the [ __ ] did i run into rash cash at
that might have been at that death row
[ __ ] too huh yeah it was at that shot
man like i did this freestyle battle in
carson like some years back you know won
like a 500 cash prize and like rash cast
is the one that paid the price though
who else is from carson is booyah trying
from out there yeah booyah tribe bishop
lamont bishop man bishop lamar was so
fired randy ray j
shout out to brandy man demetrius dan
what about rayjay
i mean yeah i was just thinking about
the whole brandy jack harlow
i was like yo she really dropped the
freestyle in 2022. that's crazy did you
hear the freestyle no i didn't you know
it was
it was good
my first writing credit was uh
brandy was on the record
really it was row james and brandy
claude plan b
wow i was off his romantic album shot
wrote james yeah shout out to bro
so brandy ray j booyah tribe bishop lama
what is bishop lamont up to i don't know
can i tell you
man
reason
of course reason demetrius
uh damn who else does d-ship make music
yeah actually he does he's he's a
talented musician i still i feel like i
saw that he did music yeah he i mean he
grew up in the church like it's crazy
like my grandparents and his
grandparents used to fellowship together
like back in the day like
he said he produced he can um
play the piano drums
yeah shout out to d should boris
whitaker carson robert woods
wait forest whitaker's from carson
they're originally from texas but they
moved to carson he might have been in
his teens
when i used to work at starbucks his
brother used to come in here all the
time i mean it's [ __ ] just like force
whitaker have you ever watched ghost dog
no i haven't seen it forest whitaker
it's like a it's like a samurai movie uh
where he plays like a black samurai in
new york
and he flies pigeons around
it's [ __ ] crazy there's actually
you saw the kendrick lamar n95 video
yeah
that was inspired by ghost dogs that's
crazy i gotta check that out yeah it's
pretty it's it's like a little indie
movie forest whitaker man yeah shout out
to my guy sylvan
uh and forest whitaker the two the two
most famous lazy eyes in the game
like i said it was too oh he was on the
rams but yeah robert woods yeah
yeah his pops is a coach on the
cardinals my team oh yeah yeah so when
they beat us
[ __ ] it was bittersweet you were at that
game i saw you i was like you're not
even a [ __ ] rams fan you're like hey
man
they gave me a jersey
because what are your raiders fan yeah
yes you was out there in that rams
jersey though they gave it to me
[ __ ] but i mean it's la i support for
sure but you're a raider fan yeah for
the record rams i live in la i'm on the
radio in l.a if you ever gave me a
jersey it's going in the garbage i know
where i bro robert woods was on the team
carson no [ __ ] part of your jerseys
los angeles rams i am an arizona
cardinals fan
to the death but see you play them
what up y'all hey we got to stop the
interview to tell you about our partners
the presenting sponsor of the bootleg
kit podcast our family at odd socks man
they're dropping so much heat at odd
socks right now go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev one word bootleg kev you
will save 20 off at checkout listen they
got the socks you know what i mean shout
out to the ninja turtles uh i totally
just dropped my
mic flag
and then they got the odd socks basics
which are just kind of like these boys
my favorites i love the odd socks basics
and let's not forget ladies and
gentlemen odd socks now has the
underwear that's right tapatio draws on
that ass remember oddssoxofficial.com
use that promo code bootleg kev save 20
off at checkout let's get back to the
podcast
play them yeah i mean yeah i mean yeah
you're in the afc right i get it yeah if
like if like yeah that's fair right it's
easy and it's the same division like
yeah yeah yeah yeah so if yeah i get it
like if you were a niner fan you
probably feel the same way i feel right
but it's like i'm like yg who was an
iron fan he's a fake ass uh rams
hey man i fan
got nothing to say matter of fact i seen
yg say the kaepernick [ __ ] that's a
that's a very good very convenient
excuse the whole nfl blackballed
kaepernick but i'm just saying like you
know that was his that was his reasoning
and then he said he grew up when he was
a kid he was a rare fan he said that on
my show yeah i know i see i'll be
watching your [ __ ] yeah he's full of
[ __ ] he's he's a [ __ ] niner fan i
know me and him have had screaming
debates about the 49ers i mean shout out
to yg and pusher uh man you know great
guys man shout out to yg i love you by
the way his shoes are super comfy
they're kind of like cortez's butt there
yeah i actually ride for a pair i didn't
you know i got two pairs i give you a
pair what size are you 11 and a half i'm
a 12. oh yeah perfect i just yeah i i
feel like i i rock the black and white
ones the red ones i'm i don't know if i
can go all red like that
sure i could do it you could do it for
sure uh so with this album why read the
room because that's literally what i did
like literally you know like kind of how
you just mentioned like a lot of people
knowing i had music but they knew it
because i was playing the back right i
was in the back while so many other
people was moving i
i literally watched like a fly on the
wall so from that position
i paid attention to what was going on
what i liked what i didn't like how i
would move if i was in this position and
et cetera and so i just read the room
before i entered it and then on the flip
side of that it's like
like i said i went to super serve my
market which was the west coast yeah
like so i had did my research of i knew
buddy boogies blasts beno's uh blue bugs
all their monthly listeners on spotify i
knew what songs was doing the most like
i really did my homework i studied what
was going on i knew what i was hearing
when i was in the streets and i just was
like okay i'm not gonna swim against the
current
um i'm gonna pay attention to what's
going on to impact
here i didn't want to rap people to
death i didn't want to make a project
trying to prove that i was just this
supreme rapper like i want to make good
music with replay value and i paid
attention to what they were playing
so uh i literally read the room again
and
then ultimately when this [ __ ] work
and you know
we go from
small time to big time and they say damn
how the [ __ ] did you get it here i'm
gonna literally tell them i read the
room i like that
how did uh because
you know obviously working with dom i
mean i feel like that you're
you could hear some of dom's influence
in in what you do
um
what was that initial link up like
um it's crazy you said you asked for the
photo yeah well the first time i met
well not the first time i like met um
like i've been seeing him around like
yeah he's around yeah like i've been
seeing him around but
uh the first person that really
introduced me to dumb and he probably
don't remember he i'm sure he doesn't
remember this [ __ ] was actually dj head
shout out my guy head yeah we were at
roddy rich's uh release party for
antisocial and it was at the end of the
night like i still got the picture and
[ __ ]
uh
i see dime outside and then dj head
walks me up to him he's like yo there's
somebody you should know that's jason
cash now i was like oh yeah it's like
yeah for sure shook hands or whatever we
took a picture
and that was it and then one day uh this
is years later i'm i'm just driving and
i caught fuzzy i'm like yo like do you
think it'd be hard to get dom on the
record
he got off the phone and called me back
maybe like in three minutes i was like
yo i'll just talk to archie we're gonna
pull up on dom next week dope so i
pulled up on him
um
i played him the song that he was on
which is him like i played him that
record
and
he was like no matter of fact i was
playing the music he was like uh
so i just pulled up the press player
like what are we doing like you know
yeah like what you want me on type of
[ __ ] so then i played on that record
because i was playing them some [ __ ]
first right this was like before
priority came on ourselves so i played a
priority was [ __ ] with it i had the
song with buddy caught the code that he
was [ __ ] with i was just playing i
was just playing him [ __ ] and then i
played him now record he was like
started over played it again
you know and he said he'll do it
so we have been waiting no no matter of
fact before the waiting period like i
ended up shooting priority that weekend
so he pulled up and was in the video and
said yeah oh damn that's crazy but we
have been waiting for the verse for a
little second and so i thought maybe he
wasn't [ __ ] with the song
so uh that song
i knew he [ __ ] with the buddy record
so i was like i took my second verse off
and was like i sent it to him like yo uh
if if this one fits you more like maybe
you can jump on this record he was like
i already did the verse you're like i
sent it to you in a second sent it to me
boom so we tripping like damn we got the
don verse that's crazy right and this at
the time the project is still it's not
called read the room or anything like
that but we've caught that groove of of
the sound yeah the sound of what we're
doing
and um
so
he sends the record back right and now
he's getting time to like you know wrap
my project up and [ __ ] so i told i asked
him can i drop the song he was like yeah
it's all good but he was like
my hard drive crashed or something like
that
so
i was like [ __ ] so you didn't have the
stems right now mind you this is the
only feature on the project at the time
that wasn't recorded in our studio right
right and one of them yeah yeah
[ __ ] right
but it was like a big blessing in
disguise because he pulled up to the
studio to re-record it
and then he was like yeah we could do
some other [ __ ] and that's how living
proof came about wow
that's crazy because a lot of times
you're [ __ ] bro shout out to that
[ __ ] hard drive crashing
because that's how i ended up with two
dom records he pulled up to re-record
the verse and then was like we started
playing records the hd boys play i was
recording to a different beat like i'm
about to get down on this [ __ ] and then
he heard some [ __ ] that [ __ ] played and
i seen his head now i'm like [ __ ] it
that's why literally the first line is i
don't push p i push opm it's because dom
was sitting in the room while i rap that
[ __ ] oh that's so hard
like
yeah what is uh obviously with this
project uh kind of your introduction
uh-huh how much uh
longer how long are you gonna wait to
drop the album
or is it just kind of to be continued
um damn ain't been out a week yet i'm
just i'm because you know sometimes like
i feel like in in 2022
music is like a it's like a weird game
it's like you do the high output thing
because people's attention spans so
small or do you wait like i feel like
you know simba dropped his project in
december of 2020
and like i feel i almost feel like he
already should have dropped another
project
so what is like kind of like are you
even are you not even thinking about
that it really just like it kind of did
because you have so much music no yeah
and i would hate for like a lot of that
music just to stay on the hard drive no
that's not that's definitely not
happening well you got a lot of [ __ ]
records not all of them probably didn't
come out but no that's definitely not
about to happen how many songs you think
you're sitting on hundreds yeah it's a
lot yeah because it was a point where i
was making like four songs four or five
songs in the night that's crazy
it was it was a point but in the same
breath like a lot of those songs it's
like it won't probably be that song like
that version on something else or yeah
you know like i like what i did on this
song i mean yeah yeah yeah or i might
revisit certain beats and do different
songs to it but um it really kind of
depends man i feel like right now when i
maximize this project for sure uh
it depends bro because like look look at
after blast with no love lost like he
had he had time but
he dropped music in between but it was
like maybe like like two years before he
dropped another project yeah he did the
deluxe yeah he did the deluxe and then
he did the three pack with the the rush
record the rest record the tiger record
yeah the rest record in the um draco
record a two-pack i'm sorry
um and then a couple other singles but
then he was on so many other people's
songs and stuff too so it just really
depends like i was literally uh play by
ear
um
to a degree but i really want to be
proactive as opposed to reactive so
uh
i have
[ __ ] in mind for sure
um if i had to double back again this
year i could for sure
for sure
but again i'm really like intentional
like i don't want to miss either right i
really feel like read the room is a
project you can literally play from top
to bottom like i did this post this poll
yesterday asking people what their
favorite song it was like the dopest
thing was so many people said different
songs so it was just like a testament of
like the project the of the project
straight to the track list and it also
showed me that they really listened to
the whole [ __ ]
that's dope because if you only have
like everyone voting on one song that's
like okay well but if everyone if it's
kind of spread out you're like oh [ __ ]
you really got something here and the
dopest part is like i mean some people
said it but not a lot of people said the
song that's actually my favorite song so
it's just like
what's your favorite song i don't care
that's my favorite song and after i
don't care if i do because sometimes
you'll be like
when you talk to someone in their album
they're like it changes every days nah
yeah nah i don't care it been my
favorite song for uh
it's been my favorite song since i made
it if i do it's like my favorite song
and while i'm rapping so that's kind of
like how i like tear it off with my
favorite overall song is i don't care i
feel like the most um
before
i probably probably the song that's the
most
i don't even want to say the most
significant to me because my outro same
is very very very much significant i'm
really talking about my life and all
that [ __ ] but selfish is what made this
project read the room
um we were in the studio and um they
were playing me beats and i just was
like man don't play me the jason cash
pack right play me the [ __ ] you play for
everybody else when you giving them like
give me that right right right like
don't box me into the rap [ __ ] like i
just got a rap and i made selfish that
night
and we caught a vibe and after that it
was just like oh this is the direction
if it was no selfish i wouldn't have
made i don't care i wouldn't have made
you know a lot of this [ __ ] i wouldn't
have made living proof i wouldn't have
made the record with kaylin right like
you know
all that came after selfish
which is like
it would be like
i wouldn't call it my favorite
but i feel like i love that one in a
different way yeah yeah because it it
means a lot of birthday projects the
sound of the project yeah it means a lot
to me well read the room is out yes sir
go run that [ __ ] up hell yeah play that
[ __ ] how many videos you got in the camp
for this um and i dropped three
i dropped well technically four because
priority but
um i definitely um
got some records at work you want to
shoot it absolutely
there it is man
it's a fuel i appreciate you pulling up
thanks for having me yes sir yes sir
i want them shoes too
i got you don't be telling me you gonna
give me something i got you and i'm
gonna and i got the excel for you i need
that
i just eat it like [ __ ]
dude i had pizza all weekend oh jesus
yeah shout out to my wife's mexican
cooking it's amazing damn she making
homemade pizzas no no no no no she made
me chilly kill us three three breakfasts
in a row memorial day weekend oh [ __ ]